Here's our optional unit. It involves programming and what I want is really simple.
I want to input a sample and a hypothesis and out should come
a simple yes or no whether whether I should accept it.
This piece of code should just do it,
and for simplicity I assume 95% confidence and two-sided-tests.
Here's what I'll do.  I'm going to give you functions you already know.
You've already programmed with the mean function. Here it is again.
Notice the use of the word float, in case the list doesn't have a float happens to be an artifact
of type conversions in Python, but never mind.
Then we have a variance function that you programmed before,
and here's the variance function in a very compact way.
And then, I also should really implement the T table but I was lazy so I'll just give 1.96,
even though we know that's not quite correct.
I'm going to give you a list. This was the list of height in my basketball club and I print the mean.
That is hard to see but I should indeed get 201.5. Give it a try.
What I want you to implement now is the function conf,
which is the plus/minus term in the confidence interval below and above the mean.
If I run it for this data sequence over here from 199 to 204, I indeed get 1.366544.
So back in  your code, we left the function conf open and please insert your code right here.
You can do this in one line.